وقد وقفت
141 دوله عضو بجانب ميثاق الامم المتحده
في حين وقفت سبعه دول الى جانب روسيا ما
من حاجه لاي تفسير اكثر
يعتمد القرار نفس المغزى الذي يعتمده
الرئيس زيلانسكي في صيغه سلام فالهدف هو
وضع خطه من عشر نقاط تستعيد احترام سياده
اوكرانيا وسلامه وسلامتها الاقليميه وفقا
لحدودها المعترف بها دوليا في امتثال تام
ميثاق الامم المتحده الذي التزمنا جميعا
باحترامه واعلائهم بايجاز هدف الخطه هو
اخراج روسيا من اوكرانيا وتحويل العالم
الى مكان اكثر امنا من البديهي ان اي
مقترحات سالم جديده يجب ان تتصق الان مع
المطالبات الوارده في القرار ندعو كافه
الدول من ربوع العالم اسرى تيسير تنفيذ
القرار وصيغه السلام نحتاج للعمل معا
وبسرعه
وضمانا للامن والسلام النوويين من خلال
دفع روسيا للانسحاب من احتلال محطه
النوويه المحتله بشكل غير مشروع وقف
هجماتها الصاروخيه التي تهدد تلك المحطات
في ربوع اوكرانيا ولتجنب تهديد الجوع يجب
دفع قطبا ومبادره الحبوب عبر البحر الاسود
وتصدي لجهود روسيا لتقويدها
وتطوير مبادرات اوكرانيا للحبوب ولمنع
ازمه طاقا يجب وقف
الارهاب الصاروخيه الروسي ضد البنيه
التحتيه الحيويه في اوكرانيا اما لحمايه
البيئه
فالقصف الروسي حرق الملايين من هكتارات
الغابات الاوكرانيه مما يهدد جهودنا
الراميه الى التصدي للاحترار العالمي ولكن
في المقام الاول يجب انقاذ الناس
حياتهم وحقوقهم تقع في صلب
مناضلاتنا للسلام فحجم الازمه الانسانيه
التي تمخضت عن العدوان روسيا ضد اوكرانيا
عظيم وهنا اود ان نصلي الضوء على واحده من
الوقائع المروعه العديده تنفذ روسيا الان
في اوكرانيا ما يعتبر اكبر حاله
لاختطاف الاطفال برعايه الدوله في تاريخنا
الحديث اعضاء المجلس الكرام
ستقاوم اوكرانيا كما كان الحال في الوقت
الماضي وستنتصر
وسيخسر بوتين في فرصه اقرب مما يعتقد
ويجب ان يعرف الروسيون والموظفين ذلك هل
تعتقدون انكم فتخرج
تنفض ايديكم مما قمتم به لا ستمثل امام
المحكمه وستشهدون
بهذا العدوان
هل تعتبرون
ان هذا الدعم
سيضعف اوكرانيا
سيعززنا من قدراتنا هل تعتبرون اننا سنتعب
من الدفاع عن انفسنا مع استمرار الهجوم
علينا سيعض ذلك من عزيمتنا
وسندحكم في الجميع ان الدعايه الروسيه
اختلقت هذا السردريائي بان امداد اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه سيؤجل الحرب ولكن اوكرانيا تحتاج
لهذه الاسلحه مثل ما يحتاج اليها رجال
الاطفال اخماد النيران فهي تدمر البيوت
وتقتل الابرياء وكلما حصلنا على المياه في
وقت اسرع كلما استطعنا اخماد النيران